they paint themselves into a corner of
not being able to send a representative
out into the world to speak honestly
about it because you're literally not
allowed to so when faced you know if
you're just sitting down with an
entertainment journalist a
representative might be able to fudge
their way through an interview but
sitting down for a long Format Interview
with someone who is going to ask them
about Xenu and the body fatens and Leah
Remini and Lisa McPherson that's a no-go
zone so so I'm representing why it will
never happen but [__] I would I would
tune in for that interview I mean I hope
you do get someone you don't think David
miscaviors sit down for an interview
I would love to be wrong you know in
general journalists in these kinds of
situations can be
um can attack
in a way that doesn't empathize and
doesn't come from a place of deep
knowledge and understanding and I think
it's possible to have serious
conversations with people like that in
an empathetic way but it's also in a
challenging way I think there's a huge
amount of trust required and obviously
for us uh very secretive organization
the amount of trust yes might be too
much required anyone over there if
they've done their homework knows you're
going to be as Fair as anyone in the
world is going to be
and yet they're simply things they're
not allowed to talk about and they're
not even allowed to say I'm not allowed
to talk about it so that's a fundamental
part of the Church of Scientology is the
secrecy yeah
so that's where you're trained as you go
up through the ranks as secrecy secrecy
it's not even a matter of training it's
that there's an entire the entire upper
half of scientology's bridge is simply
confidential I mean and I never even did
those levels when I was in Scientology I
didn't learn what scientologists
actually believe on those upper levels
until after I got out of Scientology and
I was freaking born and raised in it